私のこと覚えてるんじゃないかって期待する
前アイコン可愛いって言ってくれた
近衛黄金本当に可愛いと思うんだにゃんみんなこんにちは
弾いポッターだよみんな久しぶり臨時にして高い
僕はとっても体調が悪かったよ
持ってこねぇ madlib name 美協は僕が最近見つけた素敵な魔法をみんな
で紹介しようか紹介しないかティっ
ますパパ
今日の箱まで行っても切っても危険な魔法に見えてとってもはなんだ魔法さすごくの
ラーメンはいつもこってりさ
せません日本語で喋りますみんな煙ってしているか行けぶりっていうのは後期からおけ
るものなんでなんかちょっと危険ぽい感じがすると思うんだけども世の中には危険じゃ
ない期ぶりせもうクラ演出とかで使われるスモークっていうものがあるなぁすごいは
なぞいう
魔法学校でていたので買ってみたよ入っうわーんが水雑だなぁはすごい
50年前の入れ
みたいなねちゅうわけで今日はこれを使って煙を立てなもう作ってみると思うよとか
調べたんですけどでもこれで日本で売ってないんだよねこれでは日本で作られてない
から説明すごい変なんだ鉄ねぇ部によると煙が健康でブログです
6ドックに皆無って書いてあるね何だろうけど92健康って頭おかしいだろさあこれを
ねするとすごい興味空いてるらしいから早速やってみよたらみんな来られて
なんかその危ないものじゃないですけど人に煙何でもしこういうのを地である時は
お父さんお母さんのお許しをもらってからおうちでよね
それがあります健康で無毒って言われるとやっぱり大丈夫そうな気がしちゃうんで僕は
も考えちゃいますねっ
ああああああ
ううっ
[音楽]
yeah
こんだけ待って弱いならこれちょっとして猛威と付けなきゃいけないみたいなやつから
もう一回申しますすみます
th
ずれやばい弱まって一瞬緊急ぶりの量がねぇ
もうちょっともう一すぐでなくなりましたあっ方を持ってれちょっと麻薬が弱い
アイテムだったようだねけどすごいね読むがいっていうだけで順次そんなヤバイ気がし
ませんよ今上にいろんな魔法使いの生徒がいるんだけど所は全部一気に燃やしてみると
もうや想像力きっと
ヘアー煙りただけ
だって彼らが混乱すると思うんだじゃあさっそく上の部屋を決めただけでしていけよだ
よ
[音楽]
おっ
すっええええっ
はぁ
fs 馬のねー
[音楽]
えっ
ん
あ
2分
はーはっはっは
いっ
えっ
ああああああ
バッファーはうわー
ぶー花ブーバーンいう用ジャンパー市場へバイター
[音楽]
uh
dea
me
uh